All right, in this video I'm going to
show you
how I captured the short trades and the
long trades on Bitcoin using harmonics,
fixed range volume profile, anchored
VWAP, Fibonacci, and a few other tools
to capture the short and the long trade
of this entire range.
So harmonics and auction market theory
paired with volume profile on their own,
both are decent tools.
Together they're basically an unfair
edge, but let me show you exactly what I
mean and how I mean this. In this video
I'm going to walk you through everything
and let's build it together. But first
let's lay out some context, right? So we
have a larger fixed range volume profile
of this overall entire range of this
value that lives in here, right? So
we're using this as a very prehistoric
value from a previous cycle top acting
as current support, okay? And we can see
clearly just within this
we can see exactly how respected this
level is from the value area high to the
point of control, okay?
Now, what we're going to do is we're
going to build out the confluence
locally as price starts to unfold in
here. We're going to take an anchored
VWAP
and I like to take it from when we get
impulsive, right? So we got pretty
impulsive right here.
You can see how well respected this
anchored VWAP has been
as a dynamic resistance support and then
eventually a support resistance a
support flip, right?
So now what we're going to do is take
our good friend the fixed range volume
profile. We're going to overlay
everything in this range
as volume to identify where is fair
value. So
value area high, point of control, value
area low.
Now, I always like to look at the fib
ratios and where price respects in this
auction. So we have from this low,
right? Because we have our trending
lower lows and lower highs, lower low.
This is the last lower high. This was
our lower low. So I'm taking a Fibonacci
pull measuring the fib ratio from this
lower high
to this lower low.
And you can see how well respected the
golden pocket paired with the 72 is,
right? And then you have your dynamic
view up support coming in.
And then you also take from the lows,
right?
So from these lows down here to these
lower highs. So now you have
another 618 6672 respected zone within
this fair value. Now you can see just
from using the fixed range volume
profile
and the Fibonacci's
and the view up how insanely accurate
your trading can automatically get.
We're only really using three tools
here, right? It's very simple, very
effective.
Now we also have a monthly point of
control that I showed you way back from
the 2021 bull cycle range top, right?
Now this is where pairing harmonics can
get really really really profitable.
Now with all of this context we're going
to take the cypher pattern. So we're
going to measure it from the lows
to this high
right? Because that was our 72 and
golden pocket back test
to this 618 6672 golden pocket back test
all the way up to our last lower high
down to our lower low. Now when we're
measuring this out this hasn't happened
yet, okay?
So when you're measuring this out on a
cypher
you're looking for a move up again. So
this is lower low, a lower high. This is
kind of a higher low in context of this
local all time frame. But we still
paired a lower high in this zone, okay?
Now
what we can assume is that with this our
D wave in a cypher is going to take us
below our lower low which is our X leg,
okay?
So you're going to have this point of
control from the 2021 acting as another
magnet. You also have the monthly naked
point of control.
Now, there's other things you can pair
with it as well. There's other things
like weekly naked point of controls down
here that weren't tapped. You also have
other levels like a daily right from
prehistoric value.
But, when you're in this auction, right?
You have
your rotational value. You then have a
Cypher pattern
um basically measuring out the Fibonacci
ratios, pairing it within the auction.
Pairing it with volume tools, giving you
a better directional bias
and a projection
to your next
trade. So,
what I'm going to show you is one
the short trade that you take off of
these because with these harmonics
there's a pretty easy rule set to
follow. And when you have a bearish
Cypher like this
you're going to always
basically project that the C leg here
cannot go above the A leg, okay?
That is simple and validation for how
you structure your setups within these.
So, you can see that when we have a
projection tool such as the harmonics
we also have the auction
and we have it coming back up into the
value area high, knowing that price
should continue to come down
and take out the lows.
So, re-entering or entering a short on
the value area high in this zone,
trading the C wave down to the D wave,
right?
That's going to give you your short
setup. And off the back of the short
setup, you're actually looking for a
long setup because this is a bullish
harmonic, right? So, it's bearish in the
short term, but it's bullish in the long
term because it's technically a reversal
right pattern. So,
you take the short trade setup, you
trade from C leg down to D leg, and then
you take off of the sweep, right? Of the
point of control
SFP reclaim of monthly naked point of
control, you take the the off of that
and then you obviously want to trade
this up higher into a swing position.
Now, what I will tell you is here's the
honest problem with harmonics. If you
use them alone, the D point projection,
right? Wherever you're measuring,
whether it's here or down here to that
weekly naked point of control, whatever
confluence you can find,
um the D point projection is a specific
price,
sure, right? But the market doesn't care
about your fib ratios, right? Harmonic
patterns fail all the time when the
level they project has no volume metric
backing, okay? You get textbook, you
know, um harmonics like this all the
time
that just blow through the D point or
the, you know, the D leg because nobody
was defending that price.
On the flip side, if you only use volume
profiles, you have great context, right?
So this is our volume profile.
You know where value lives. You know
where the point of control magnets are.
You don't have a specific trigger, but
you know some, you know, something
matters around this zone, right? And we
had confluence in this zone. We had a
lot of support in this zone. Um one of
the bigger confluences is that we had a
618 of the all-time high. So you're
taking this as a 618, right? Measuring
the largest golden pocket you can do,
which is all the way from the lows of
Bitcoin all the way to the highs of
Bitcoin, right? And that's giving us
exactly our 618, which is where we
bottomed out, okay? Now you're pairing
that with a few other confluences,
right? Such as the monthly naked point
of control. So when you zoom in, you can
really see that SFP that happened. So
let's get rid of these just for the
noise. You can clearly see we had
monthly naked point of control holding.
You then had
a flush.
You tapped the 618.
You came back, flipped the point of
control from the 2021 all-time high,
right? The bull run.
Point of control, right? And then you
flipped the monthly naked point of
control as support and you ran up,
right? So there's a
entire narrative to this harmonic
paired with whatever magnet, right? Is
is is happening. So you can't just say,
you know what? I'm going to long
as soon as it comes down and completes
this D wave. That's not necessarily how
that works because you have to have
volumetric tools and you have to have
fib ratios that would be respected and
you have to have a good auction, right?
So we're taking a very higher time frame
fixed range volume profile volumetric
point of control that happened
prehistorically, you know, 4 or 5 years
ago.
And you were using this as local
confluence with how price is unfolding
now.
So this combo solves both problems,
right? The harmonic gives you the
specific price to watch.
Volume profile tells you where that
price actually matters, right? It
mattered really really nicely in here.
And it mattered here when we rejected to
know that we're coming back down into
it, right?
And when they line up, you're not
guessing. You're waiting for a level the
auction has already voted on, right? So
the point of this video isn't the trade,
right? It isn't It isn't any one of
these trades, okay?
The point of this video is that anyone
can point at a chart in hindsight,
right? You can always come back and be
like, "Oh, that was such an easy short
or easy long, right?"
Harmonic like what I'm trying to tell
you is volume profile won't give you a
trigger.
Um harmonics alone won't also give you
an entry, but you combine them and you
get a high conviction entry at prices
the market has already agreed on that
matter. It has to matter. These levels
have to line up. You have to have
confluence. You have to have context.
You have to have narrative. And when you
pair up volume profile tools, you pair
in harmonics, you basically um you get a
very very high
probable read on the market of where the
next pivot is going to be and how to
capture on that reversal.
So
if you want to see how I read these
setups in real time, our Orochi Discord
link is in the description.
Um the free side has plenty, right? But,
premium is where this full framework
lives. How we teach it, right? Powerful
framework,
powerful front uh mindset. Um so, we'll
go ahead and we will see you in the next
video. Cheers.